Something that I will be,
uh,
charting as we move through the episodes,
that makeup,
uh,
parked who is,
how they are reminiscent of others in part one,
how in many cases these episodes in part to our rewritings of episodes in part
one,
this is an issue,
uh,
that doesn't have to be just,
stated,
but also pondered,
I mean,
what does that mean?
Uh,
does it make a statement about there not being a possibility of a,
of something new and original,
uh,
of memory impinging on the presence so strongly that you cannot really move away
from it,
uh,
on and so forth.
So,
uh,
so when I discussed this episodes,
I will,
uh,
tried to,
to link them to episodes in part one.
And I hope that you do the same as you,
uh,
as you read because the,
the,
the book invites you to do so,
uh,
from the very beginning when,
Samsung Carrasco sort of takes over as the,
uh,
as the internal author of part two,
and you realize that wasn't so Carrasco once Gnocchi Quixote to do is to reenact
part one to be like it was in part one and to do the things that we did in part
one and in fact many of the characters in part to,
uh,
that the,
the,
the Don Quixote on Jo meet one them to act like as they did in part one.
So,
uh,
this is something that can be seen as a sort of an overarching topic about,
in my discussions of part two.
And that I hope that you,
uh,
we'll also,
do us,
you as you read them and think about,
uh,
part two.
We are going to begin,
uh,
today,
where we left off in the last class talking about that all important term,
uh,
that I,
was discussing called the Sin Ganja.
Okay.
The same guy I knew was perhaps the most important concept of the Spanish
Baroque.
Remember Baroque is essentially 17th century spilling over into the 18th century
where it becomes rococo if you want to be more precise.
So this in Ganja is perhaps the most important concept of the Spanish Baroque.
It means on deceiving opening ones,
eye to eyes to reality,
awakening to the truth.
These are all valid translations of the term in Guy knew,
uh,
in Spanish means deceit to be fooled thing gang means I fooled you.
This,
uh,
a is to full oneself.
This concept is,
is fundamental to park too because the whole plot of the novel seems to be
moving towards distribution meant.
Uh,
so let me give you some definitions of this in Ganja and comment on them so that
we can have as clear a concept or as clear an idea of this concept as possible.
The first is from a Otis Green on his book,
Spain and the Western tradition.
All these green was a great,
uh,
Hispanic is that the University of Pennsylvania for many years,
through the forties,
50s and 60s.
And his book is,
is,
uh,
um,
was a treasure of information about a Spanish literature and culture of the
Golden Age.
He writes this,
this,
and Daniel is related to the sort of awakening to the nature of reality that the
prodigal son must have experienced.
I will arise and go to my father says the prodigal son.
This waking to true awareness is called [inaudible] in La Quinta in Spanish.
It's another way of
Diana in La Quinta
do have the scales fall from our eyes to see things as they are.
So just state of mind is desirable.
I continue with green.
This illusion men comes to be viewed even to be venerated as a sword of wisdom.
The wisdom of the STOIC Sapians or wise man over antiquity who was fully aware
of what constituted the sumo boardroom,
the supreme good and was utterly are enticed by everything else.
Um,
quote,
you know who the stoics were.
So this,
uh,
Weiss stoic man,
knew what the real good was and what was not valuable.
Guy [inaudible] gone with another quote from,
from green to come to oneself was the phrase most used in connection with the
type of dissing Ganja we are considering here in signified it passing from
ignorance to knowledge and awakening from the falsity of one's dream on quote.
So you can see,
uh,
now,
the,
uh,
the dialectic as it were between and guide you on this in Ganja deceit and on
the seat the seat,
uh,
on dissolution went un UN.
I'm coming to realize what is the true,
the following is the quote that I gave you at the end of the last class.
It was on the back of that map with the uh,
uh,
donkey Hotez a route,
on the way to uh,
Saragosa and then the,
uh,
swerve to Barcelona.
And it's the following and it is from Baltasar [inaudible]
Baltazar Garcia [inaudible] was a Jesuit who wrote about politics with on
rhetoric.
He lived between 1601 and 1658.
And he wrote a very famous allegorical novel,
an allegorical anomalies and normally with your character represent
obstructions,
reason,
truth and so forth.
And the novel is called Goody Gum.
Okay.
The big critic,
uh,
here is a quote from that book is a quote that you have is a court about this
and Ganja,
the most monstrous of all is the placing of deceit,
the seat at the world's front gate,
and this elution meant at the exit,
a disastrous handicap,
sufficient to ruin our life entirely since to make a misstep at the beginning of
life causes one to lurch head long with greater speed,
speed each day and end up in order perdition.
Who made such an arrangement?
Who ordained it?
Now I am more convinced than ever that all is upside down in this world.
This illusion when should stand at the world's entrance,
I should place himself immediately at the shoulder of the neo fight to free him
from the dangers that lie in.
Wait for him,
but since the newcomer,
bye bye,
bye.
An opposite and contrary arrangement makes his first encounter with deceit who
are the beginning,
presents everything to him in perverted and reversed order.
He heads for the left hand,
wrote on strides onto the structure.
As you can see,
this is a very allegorical.
The left hand wrote,
the left is always the bad sinister sinister admins left.
Uh,
this is why it has that connotation.
the left road is,
is the bad road.
And uh,
so did you have,
uh,
deceit and disillusionment,
and he says,
is placing a deceit at the,
this is the door to life,
uh,
seat is here.
And then the end of life is the other deek visit.
Emotion meant this is what he is saying.
Uh,
Garcia was very allegorical,
uh,
in his,
mode of thinking.
Okay.
The seats are all of Loki holders,
illusions and those of the other characters in the novel,
while the thing Daniel is what they wind up or what they reach,
a disillusionment,
realizing that it is all vanity of vanities.
This is the reason why so much of what happens in part two is staged deceit is
the theatricality of so many events which are made up,
constructed the seed.
The seed is the dream of books that Don Quixote Dreams.
It is the unbroken chain of texts,
masking reality,
and even have language also masking reality.
So Don Quixote's dream of books,
these illusions about the,
uh,
Romances of [inaudible] and the knights of old is a deceit.
And disillusionment is coming to realize that it is,
that,
that it is nothing but it'd be seat.
Uh,
and the,
the unbroken chain of texts is because,
uh,
in Gnocchi halters mind,
one text leads to another,
leads to another,
leads to another.
It's a humanist dream.
The humanists who had,
who were philologist lovers of language,
uh,
Star students of,
of,
of the classics thought in terms of,
of texts leading to text,
leading to texts,
uh,
without ever getting to reality and of language of something that,
that has its own reality and whatever rogue does is,
uh,
undermined or of that and show that it is all a dream.
The best example
of these pattern of deceit and disillusionment or of going from the seat to
disillusionment is the play by Calderon de la Barca.
Life is a dream.
I have buddies name before on the board.
What?
I will do it again.
So do you remember him?
He's one of the classics of Spanish literature.
You can't see from there.
No Baraka Sob.
Bali.
I am very fond of [inaudible] life is a dream because I wrote my entire doctoral
dissertation about that play and uh,
it is one of the classics of Spanish literature in,
but play life is a dream and English prince [inaudible] door has been kept in a
tower since birth because an omen told his father king Basilio that say his moon
though would be a ruthless tyrant if he became,
if he ever became king.
So he has him grow up since he's a baby in a tower,
cared for by a glottal door and so forth
to put them into a test.
Basilio has a,
so he's Moonglow drugged and brought to the palace where when he awakens,
he's treated like a king.
Confused.
Uh,
so he's Mondo act violently,
uh,
tries to rape a woman,
throws a soldier off a balcony,
uh,
and and so forth,
confirming the omen in a way.
Uh,
so he's drugged and brought back to the power where,
uh,
upon awakening,
he does not know if what happened in the Paris was true or just the dream.
Meanwhile,
the people who have found out about the,
his Mondo,
uh,
about,
say he's Moondance existence the people in the kingdom,
a revolt and come to get him to fight again,
his father.
So he's wound or hesitates because he does not know if this is another dream,
what decides to go with them and act prudently and just me this time because he
realizes that even in dreams,
it is best to do the good
because if life is like a dream,
the only true life is a life after death.
He did,
throws his father but does not kill him and marries the woman he should marry,
not the one he had lost it after,
during his first day in the palace,
he controls his desires.
The message is that life may very well be like a dream in a platonic sense,
but even so,
one must behave morally.
As you can see,
uh,
the plot of the play which I have simplified,
goes from the seat,
the first visit to the palace to disillusionment.
Wednesday he's wounded,
Awakens back in the tower and wisdom when it comes to know that life is like a
dream as our political power,
the trappings of government on everything else.
The only thing that,
uh,
by the way that he knows what's true,
when he awakens in the tower is his love for this woman.
The only continuity is the emotion of love and those are the neoplatonic element
in the play.
It's a more complicated play that I have just made it seem here.
We will,
we will have occasion,
uh,
we,
we will,
we will see a very similar story when Santo becomes a ruler later in the green.
Becky haughty.
My suggestion here
is that the plot of the Quixote as a whole follows is similar outline from the
seed to this solution from an ganja to disingenuous.
We will have of course occasion to revisit this when we come to the end of the
novel.
But,
uh,
keep it in mind.
Also keep all of this in mind.
Also,
when you read for next week,
the wonderful,
uh,
story,
the Glass Graduate Ellison Seattle,
which you are to read for next week.
Next week we have a big week,
we have the glass graduate and also we are going to be doing two of the main
essays in the casebook,
the ones by Spitzer and by our back about whom I spoke in the last class
already.
So you should be prepared to read the essay of the enchanted Dulcinea and
episode that we're going to be discussing here today.
This is where we can keep our course,
uh,
not going from the seat to the solution meant,
but we wide-eyed about everything from the very
beginning.
So let us begin today as we move to the episodes in the Quixote,
uh,
about the discussion of Don Quixote and Santo about night errands and saints
that I'm sure you remember first.
There is the extraordinary room,
my CD I made happening Hayley and comments by the narrator about the,
what the translator said,
uh,
or what the narrator said about see them at their wedding.
Haley,
but the reader does not,
does not know where these comments appeared.
And we talked about that in the last class.
They are not in in the text as it were,
but in a sort of metatech or virtual text that is not a running commentary about
the composition of the novel.
And this is one,
a new feature in part two that I mentioned before.
Now Saint Joe's subjects Don Quixote to rigorous cross examination and gets him
to say that saints are better than nights.
I'm sure you remember that.
Uh,
central has rhetorical skills as those Samsung who earlier had used them,
had used forensic rec rhetoric to ease don Quixote's.
Sally sandstone may have acquired those skills in Salamanca,
but where did sent Joe learned them or anything else?
Where did essential learn rhetoric or it was all of this culture that he has in
his mind?
I think that the integration is that,
uh,
central has learned a great deal,
not just from donkey haughty,
which he does and we have seen,
but also from hearing sermons at Church,
which he mentions in his discussion with his wife.
The church is on this level,
part of popular culture or better Evie ego for the popularization of culture.
Saint George might not know how to read,
but he has a culture in his head that he has absorbed from the preachers.
This is one way to explain the evolution of sanctuary.
And he's,
uh,
increased,
intellectual,
uh,
on rhetorical,
powers.
Although of course,
uh,
he's,
he's he relationship with donkey hotels.
I will mention in a,
in a,
in a couple of minutes is obviously the most important,
the discussion per se,
the theme,
the topic of the discussion is very serious here too,
because he plays into a religious debates of the time in Spain who's background
is the reformation.
The debates have to do with good works and with predestination,
predestination and free will.
A
Protestant,
uh,
sided with predestination,
Catholicism or at least one,
uh,
one,
element within Catholicism,
the most important one for freewill.
So therefore,
if you have free will,
you could through good actions,
gain access to heaven.
Now this,
these are debates that to us is our secular age seem vacuous.
Uh,
but they were not in the 16th century at all.
There were of the upmost important.
So here in this discussion,
it is not just a question of arms visit versus letters,
uh,
which is a set discussion piece,
although there is a reminiscence of that here.
Uh,
but of good actions for their own sake and good actions for the sake of glory.
Sanctuary shows that the knights actions seem to be of this second kind actions
to gain glory.
And this feeds into the topic of dissing Ganja and in Ganja.
So to perform actions for the sake of glory is to perform actions for the sake
of deceit of in Ganja Gnocchi.
Haltech counters by saying that they were knights who were saints.
Uh,
I suppose that he refers to St George particularly,
and ads that are not everyone can be a monk.
He says Cervantes is,
I think pity is relativistic and liberal take on life,
which is not antireligious against the religious zealots of the time.
I think through this discussion of his characters.
So the discussion has a contemporary relevancy that is political as well as
religious.
And this is connected to what I said in one of my earlier lectures about the
fact that part two is the first political novel because religious and religion
and politics were intertwined,
uh,
in this pain of the 16th and 17th century with all the caveats that we have
learned,
uh,
by reading Elliot.
So this discussion of the two characters about this issue is consonant with the
political side of part two.
I want to underline that so that you have that clear in your mind.
Okay.
Now,
central also demonstrates as he has before and as he will increasingly that he
is endowed with natural reason,
natural reason,
uh,
which can lead him to understand sufficiently the most difficult questions.
Natural reason is,
is a medieval
that survives through the renaissance and reaches the enlightenment,
which underscores God's gift of sufficient reason to every individual,
no matter what his station in life.
To understand the fundamental question of issues of life,
this will become an important topic in part to natural resource.
And sanctuary will be the exemplar of this.
It is a theological construct.
Now
one can see of course that uh,
that because,
uh,
saint Jo has been influenced by donkey haughty,
their arguments are like discussions the night could be having within himself or
with himself.
What is the significance of their mutual influence?
I think that to propose a concept of the self as relational,
not as individual or isolated,
not,
I think therefore I am the god of course,
which comes a little later.
Uh,
not so much.
I think therefore I am as I relate to others and myself emerges from that
commerce or dialogue with others.
This is what they can hope that through this relationship between these two
characters seems to be suggesting.
Now,
of course,
this is a very profound philosophical statement or suggestion,
uh,
but it is also crucial in the development of modern fiction.
Think of huck and Jim in huckleberry Finn a of their dialogues and have their
influence on each other.
Think of doc,
uh,
of,
of Holmes and Dr. Watson.
To give you an example from popular culture and even of those Faulknerian
characters that seem to overlap and blend into each other.
To the point that you sometimes don't know who's really speaking to one of these
Faulkner's novels,
you don't because of these characters consciousness of sort of blended and and
the individuality has been eroded and this is what I'm suggesting is happening
here in Gnocchi Day and sanctuary and why this argument is one that [inaudible]
could have had within himself.
Now this discussion also brings up Doki hottest knowledge of classical Rome and
its architecture.
Rome is the par excellence in the renaissance and its architecture was the model
for renaissance architect.
This shows remember that Cervantes spent what a bit of time in Italy,
so when he speaks of Rome,
he's speaking not only a of things he had read about in books,
but also thinks that he has seen
now these shelves or Don Quixote is a humanist that he has read beyond the
romances of chivalry.
In part two we are beginning to enlarge Doki halters library.
We cannot reduce it to the romances of chivalry that we found with the barber
and priest and uh,
in,
in the s the scrutiny of the books.
But he bought,
he had read other things.
Uh,
you don't,
so anticipate part two,
part two's projection beyond Spain.
I say beyond Spain because us don't be haughty.
And Santiago to Barcelona,
they are moving to a part of Spain that is almost not Spain
Babylonia being even today a part of Spain that uh,
it's,
it's very independent in its culture and,
and has and has in fact,
uh,
tried to become independent thought several times.
So,
uh,
and also of course the,
the,
the battles that you will see at the end of the book beyond the shores of
Barcelona are a move beyond,
uh,
the borders of Spain.
So this projection towards Italy is important in that respect.
But also this discussion points out that architecture is an important issue in
part to,
uh,
you send important,
issue.
Uh,
because,
uh,
as I have mentioned before,
a great deal of part two takes place indoors in,
in houses and mansions.
And so forth,
uh,
in part to,
we have less,
although there are some of those two places that I mentioned in a part one the
desk,
blah,
this blah,
blah.
This boy brow the unpopulated.
Remember that that is a even illegal,
uh,
concept,
that area where the law does not reach,
uh,
on the other one that I didn't put on the board.
But you must have seen the word many times.
These are the solid bodies.
So they now this are,
uh,
what'd you are out in the wild?
Okay.
There's less of this impart to a more of shelter,
more of architecture.
And this is why the discussion on Roman architecture is important,
uh,
above all in the context of,
of,
of humanism and the renaissance and the copying of Rome,
uh,
Rome's architecture.
And then of course the development of what would become baroque architecture.
And that scheme that I gave you about buying a plaza sterling memorial,
you blend them,
uh,
forced them together and you get the baroque.
No,
this emphasis on cities brings us to the entry into El Toro Rosso.
MMM.
The third,
Sally takes place at night.
Okay.
And at night goes,
a day goes by and then at night they enter this,
the,
the town,
the village of a divorcee.
Uh,
and uh,
being at night,
uh,
this anticipates much of the mood of part two.
Remember part one began,
uh,
dawn,
um,
don't get hauled down San Jo,
uh,
one to arrive in the town at night,
so it's not to be noticed.
And that night is called in,
in the Spanish.
Ooh,
not Norcia.
In three,
Clara,
uh,
at night that was not quite a dark one.
Says,
uh,
Jarvis.
Uh,
and this,
uh,
I underlined because of the concept of Chiaroscuro that I mentioned before,
the concept of Chiaroscuro,
uh,
as,
something,
uh,
proper,
but road that Norcia in the retail Herrera,
there's darkness.
Sounds
okay.
Dogs Barking,
donkeys,
brain swine grunting cards.
Mewing Miellyn a plow being dragged.
Uh,
that is an eagerness to his town augmented by this,
uh,
by the sound the farm had the farm they meet is singing a song about a great
defeat defeat,
which adds to the,
the omens,
the bad omens sounds as opposed to visual science appear before them.
In part one we had the fooling hammers,
but in part two there will be many more sounds.
Uh,
as you will see,
this sounds here are scary by virtue of the fact that you cannot see their
source.
You could only hear seeing is going to be a different problem in part two
because of the increasing darkness.
This is the first time that Don Quixote on central come into a town and it
anticipates the enter into Barcelona as a city,
a great city towards the end of the novel.
What is the significance of this?
I have mentioned this,
the novel which develops from the Quixote will be for the most part on urban
jar,
the jar.
How about often about cities?
Modern cities and don't keyholders influence on the history of the novel
includes this,
uh,
urban park of,
of the Quixote,
particularly as you will see you when you get to the Barcelona chapters here.
It also appears as a haunted city with blind alleys and people by strangers the
the farm had,
who do not know,
uh,
anything about it.
The farm hand is an outsider who cannot give them directions.
I have always been always been parceled and sort of even scared by these farm
hand in the middle of night who doesn't even know where he is.
And I think I know why and if you will allow me a little anecdote.
I was lost in the Pennsylvania turnpike at night once trying to find the town in
probably called Indiana,
Pennsylvania,
where I was giving a lecture.
I got off the turnpike and I was lost,
uh,
in little towns in Pennsylvania,
were dark with little lights.
I A,
I drove my rented car,
uh,
towards the sidewalk sidewalk because I saw a man coming.
I lowered the window and I said,
could you tell me how to get to the turnpike?
And he went,
I'm deaf,
I'm deaf as,
Oh God,
he's deaf.
He can't help me.
I raised the window and I followed and I found a little gas station with one
little light bulb.
And I,
and I got off the car and this guy came out.
We only one eye.
He had a hole on the other side,
said this guy can't help me.
And so I was lost for hours.
They were about to send for the National Guard.
I finally found,
uh,
Indiana,
of Pennsylvania where I was lodged in a,
in a holiday inn with a Mexican motif.
And I was given the Taco Room.
So,
so this is,
this is my anecdote and this is what brings to mind this farm hand who appears
in the middle of the night.
I can be of any help because he doesn't know anything.
He's not from there.
So,
uh,
there are deep,
residences to me of Spanish mysticism in this dark night of the soul to echo
Saint John of the cross,
the great Spanish mystic poet.
It's the name of one of his great poems,
Nachi Scooter,
the landmark.
It recalls seeing the depths of the soul in the darkness of night.
Sam Cho is actually looking for a memory that is the lie,
the story he made up about going to a torso,
remembering something that he does know that he knows those not existence.
Trying to remember something that he knows does not exist so it made up memory
and Don Quixote is looking for a non existent lady who is the object of his
devotion.
Both protagonists are searching for intangibles in the dark of night as as as if
it were within their troubled spirits and this is the,
I think the impression that this whole torso at night conveys
right away we come upon the line that has inspired much useless commentary when
looking for Doosan air.
They run into the church.
The line in Spanish reads going like less shy.
Most daughter or son Joel Jarvis translates.
We are come to the church.
Central modern readers have have seen in in that sentence a hidden meaning that
he said Cervantes is decry.
The interference of the church in all affairs and the line has even become a
standard phrase in Spanish.
To see that you have come against some obstacle going,
like going like Alicia Masato sanctuary when you come against some obstacle,
particularly when you are denied something or other.
I think that it's only because of the rhythm of the,
of,
of the way the sentence is written,
not Ms. Dot.
Logan Alessia,
Sandra,
what colleague?
Lecia Mcdonald's.
Andrew.
But it doesn't have anything to do with that.
This is why I mean that it is useless,
but it has remained in the Spanish language as a readymade phrase.
Uh,
I think that what is significant here is that Lucy Nass,
Hassell has morphed into the church that in looking in the dark for duty castle,
they have found a church or the church in the gloom where things are difficult
to identify sanctuary scared because he knows that the cemeteries are around
churches and he doesn't want to be in a cemetery at night.
This could be a telling transformation,
perhaps an indication that don Quixote's love is a kind of religion or more
likely given what will happen over and again in part two is an intimation of
death of which there are many in this eerie chapter,
this ghostly 19 Ilta worship,
uh,
the first adventure in part two sets the tone for the rest of the novel.
So now we move to the chapter.
We're not going to go through every single chapter as I've mentioned before,
but here we moved to the a very important chapter.
The one on the enchanted Dulcinea is important,
not only because it inspired our backs,
fables essay on the enchanted do scenario that you will be reading,
but also it is a chapter that will play an important role later in one of the
most important episodes,
uh,
of part two,
one of the whole Quixote,
the episode of the Cave of Montesinos where this enchanted duty.
Now we'll come back.
Uh,
so
first of all,
it is one episode in which we notice once again,
but very dramatically an exchange of roles between donkey healthy and Santo.
Uh,
the first time was when Sanchez played the role of Don Quixote to his wife who
was playing his own role in that,
in that hilarious dialogue that they had.
But here,
uh,
the,
the exchange of roles,
uh,
is much more,
a dramatic,
the first thing to notice is Sanchez Shakespearian monologue,
uh,
that dramatizes is inner conflicts and reveals his apprehensions about donkey
Quixote.
He doesn't know quite what to do.
He is Sanchez here like a rustic hamlet to be or not to be.
Uh,
he,
he weighs the various options that he has.
And,
uh,
he ops for trying to fool don Quixote with the,
with the,
uh,
trick of the,
of,
of turning this peasant women into scenario,
centuries becoming a fuller character and increasingly important to the novel.
He is one of the pranksters who fooled Okie hotel.
He will be in the sense like,
uh,
Samsung Carrasco unlike the Duke Stewart who will appear later also sanctuary
separated from his master here,
asked when he went to deliver the letter in part one.
But this prefigures several important episodes in part two in which they are
separated and central place,
uh,
the role of the protagonist of his own part.
Uh,
but the most important thing about this Shakespearean monologue as I call it,
is that we are exposed,
uh,
here to Sanchez inner world,
his world of doubts.
Yeah.
Then of course there is the inversion of Rowe sanctuary is the one trying to
convince his master,
but what they see is not everyday reality but something drawn from what you've
added with romances.
And He,
he does a pretty good imitation of don Quixote,
his own rhetoric in trying to convince him that this wench is a [inaudible].
So reality was no Quixote perceives as it is,
conspires spontaneously or arranged by someone to appear as on real literary
artificial.
Hence the episode depends on the memory of part one and have similar episodes
here.
I think that the episode in the background is that of the windmills setting
version.
It is here.
Gnocchi,
Oklahoma.
Who says what?
Giants.
Oh,
what do you,
where is Lucy now?
What do you mean?
Boosie now
that is the episode in the background here.
Now the peasant,
uh,
last,
react to Santos rhetoric a little bit like the prostitutes in the first in a
will they react to the hotel door,
the prostitutes in the first inward kind of to look.
Quixote done this done this,
uh,
peasant women here who are very upset because they think that opera class,
young men or men are making fun of them.
This is really a truly hilarious episode.
Uh,
one that makes me laugh if I said that's I said the last time,
uh,
every time I reread it,
particularly the part about,
uh,
[inaudible] smelling of garlic,
um,
which I would mention again.
Uh,
but there is also the issue of see Nas bodily hair
specifically in donkey halters interpretation.
Do See Nass pubic hair.
MMM.
If we go to page
five 30 by 31,
Sandra is talking and he says,
uh,
by which we might have guests.
Well,
what was hid beneath that course?
This guy's,
he's talking about her body,
not to say the truth to me.
She did not appear in the list be formed,
but rather all beauty.
And that increased to buy a mole she had on her right lip lack a whisker with
seven or eight hairs on it,
like threads of gold and above is span long.
Tom Harris as Mo.
This is a Berlanti answer by donkey whole day.
According to the correspondence,
there is between the moles of the face and those of the body don't see,
I should have another on the bronze of her thigh,
the inner part of her thigh on the same side with that,
uh,
on her face.
But Harrison of the lens you mentioned are somewhat of the longest.
The formals just are going to show your worship bouncers,
Sandra,
that there they were and look to see if they had been born with her.
I believe in friends that don't get hot there for nature has placed nothing
about Nokia for nature,
has placed nothing about [inaudible],
but what is finished and perfect and therefore how Chia hundred moles like those
you speak of in their,
uh,
in her,
in her they would not be moles,
but news under splendid stars.
Uh,
the description is to be mindful of course,
of meritorious,
but there is something specific about a hairy dude [inaudible] bodily hair,
huh?
A lot of hair was taken.
Venice,
an indication of a sexuality
all have a strong sexual drive.
These and other hints,
there will be other hints on there have been others.
You can look them up in my book love and the law instead of scientists of bodily
hair on Lucinia and other women mustaches and so forth,
look for them.
Now as you read the book and believe me,
they are there,
haven't invented them.
Uh,
these and other hints reveal a story behind the story here that I have hinted at
before.
What lurks beneath Donkey Quixote's courtly love style for those scenarios is
the sexual desire of an Aristocrat for a peasant last presumed to be of ardent
sexuality who promises to provide more pleasure than the women of his class.
That is a literary tradition behind this that reaches back to the Spanish
balance.
But he's also quite alive instead of anthesis time,
at least two of the ones,
conquests,
you know,
who don't want to answer the figure of the wand and womanizer and so forth who
first appeared in TV.
So there Molina's play.
I've mentioned the fact that the,
the one figure is one of the figure created in the Spanish golden age by dear.
So the Molina,
I better put his name on to,
uh,
he is the inventor of their own,
one figure of great,
uh,
legacy then in literature and music and so forth.
At least two of the ones conquest in,
in digital Molina's play the tricks there of Seville are from the lower classes.
One of the Pesach and the other,
a Fisher woman.
That dual scenario in this scene also underscores her physical prowess.
By the way,
she mounts her donkey by taking the little run back to get some momentum and uh,
leaving on it from behind and writing it as strike like a man.
It's a very sexual and vulgar gesture that you make that I find absolutely
hilarious.
And then when Santo says,
Oh my God,
she's quite a horseman,
she could teach a quarter or a Mexican to,
to ride a horse the way that she,
she leaps on it.
And she just goes on also by her smell of raw garlic,
uh,
which,
Jarvis translates as on digested garlic,
which reveals her coarseness and also,
but her proximity to food,
food and sex go together.
Now I know that of course garlic doesn't sound very sexy to anybody anymore or
ever perhaps.
But this is the intimation,
the whole transformation of dual scenario.
We'll leave a deep imprint in the nights subconscious as we shall see in the
episode of Montesinos his cave.
But now don Quixote on Santo are about to meet theater on the road.
This road that in part two appears to be full,
nor have real characters as of characters and objects playing roles or this guy
or something else other than what they are.
So the meet now the cart of the parliament of death,
which is a card carrying actors who have finished putting on a play in one town
and go to another nearby to repeat the performance.
Hence they have not changed,
uh,
out of their costumes.
The play that they stage the they stage is a kind that you have already met
before.
The very briefly in the resource and Marcella episode,
if you remember that episode,
[inaudible] was said to write the out of Sacramento outdoors,
sacrum sacrament,
Dallas.
MMM.
These are the religious place performed,
uh,
on the day of Corpus Christi.
The feast in honor of the Eucharist or communion,
celebrate it on a Thursday,
on the 60th day after Easter.
Therefore,
it,
uh,
it's,
um,
uh,
go here with the,
with the chronology of the novel is taking place in summer.
So,
uh,
Corpus Christi a communion,
the Eucharist is celebrated in this,
uh,
in this feast every year on a part of the feast was the performance of this
place.
Uh,
uh,
which always deal with the topic of the Eucharist,
the mystery of the Eucharist,
the transformation or body of Christ body into blog and into wine and bread.
They usually have plots,
uh,
drawn from scripture,
but also blood's drawn from,
from classical mythology.
This,
this outdoors weren't a medieval retention in every sense.
And now think of what I said about the baroque going back to the middle age,
just jumping over back over the renaissance.
This is a medieval retention.
The out to Sacramento,
there were one act plays performed on carts.
Precisely.
They are carrying themselves on the cart and they also carrying with the cart
the stage because the way that is outdoors where performed,
uh,
where if you have a town square,
say the church is here,
uh,
all their buildings and so forth,
the carts were put one,
if there were two or three,
one for each scene and then the people was,
uh,
would be here.
The performance to place on the carts and elaborate,
uh,
props,
um,
and uh,
uh,
and,
and scenery,
uh,
were created on the carts because he's plays,
represented cosmic events.
So the world,
I mean the universe does Doris and so forth,
it would appear.
And then when the play was finished,
this was a very modest played with only one cart.
The cart's would move on to the next town.
So they were carrying with him the,
uh,
their stage and not only themselves,
but also their stage.
Um,
they,
uh,
they were simply enough so that all the people could understand them,
but sophisticated in versification imagery of theological content.
God,
they don't.
Delivery.
[inaudible] was the most famous author of outdoor sacrament,
but many other poets and playwrights wrote them,
including Lopa,
the Vega,
who was the author of the one mentioned in this episode,
the last quarter's they'll a Morton,
which is a real one act play by Lopez Rega.
Uh,
translate it here as the courts or parliament of,
of death in the play.
Man With a capital m remembers an allegorical play,
um,
is subjected to a trial after having been tempted by the devil.
This is where the devil appears here.
Uh,
I know their figure is that of madness represented by the actor who spooks resy
Nantais with this bells and bladders.
You remember this one who came,
who comes after they have had their dialogue and his has a stick with some,
the beginning they didn't have balloons because of course there was no plastic
to make them.
So they made a,
they made these balloons out of their bladders of slain animals.
So bladders and belts and he plays,
he plays madness.
The most famous of these outposts was one by Calderon called the great theater
of the world.
Uh,
whose theme was that of the world as a stage where man performs life as if it
were a play before going on to the real life after death at the end of the play,
the one performed by these players in this,
uh,
episode of [inaudible],
who,
by the way,
we're a real company of actors,
uh,
of the time.
It's very much along the lines of the,
of the great theater of the world.
But,
but the,
the conceit here is that of a trial,
uh,
four man.
So this is what is in the background of this,
uh,
of the scene.
Um,
so theatricality is an important element in part because of what I mentioned.
Theatricality is part of the deceit that would lead to the same ganja.
Uh,
but it's also,
you will also find that at the end where he knows their parsimony appears as a
puppet master death who appears here as,
as part of the ensemble of actors because death was an allegorical figure that
appeared in this,
uh,
is also important in part two and is a medieval retention.
So is the devil.
Uh,
everyone here is in costume including of course,
Don Quixote.
Reality is already play illusion.
There is no need for donkey halted to misinterpreted,
but notice the subtlety that the place then assume their roles.
In reality,
the devil begins the madness begins to play madness,
uh,
in the reality of Don Quixote.
Uh,
okay.
The devil plays a trick on sanctuary and the presence of death even in how they
go.
Wrinkled dress is frightening and a reality is buried beneath a layer of uh,
various forms of representation and man dressed as a literary character meets
men and women dressed as literary characters.
The devil who still central's donkey parodies,
donkey,
haughty and his fall from Racine.
Auntie here is a madman facing an actor playing the role of madness because if
reality were offering don Quixote a mirror of his own deranged self,
this is something that will happen over and again in part two,
we will meet it.
We would meet,
uh,
we'll find another example very soon when Gnocchi Quixote meets the night of the
mirrors,
life is play acting as donkey Hilton says,
using a word that you are now familiar with.
He says,
Yo,
Digo [inaudible] Badadada Luga I'll Destin,
Ganja.
That's what it says in the original and your is those reasonably well.
He says,
and I say now that it is absolutely necessary.
There's no Quixote,
uh,
if one would be on the thieved this in Ghana to lay one hands upon appearances
to see if they that they are appearances.
Cervantes by the way,
is punning here because in the Spanish of the 17th century,
I party NCS also meant stage props when when God their own wrote instructions
for the carpenters to make the stage,
he called those memorial.
The [inaudible] answers were stage props.
So by these pumps,
advantage is underlying.
[inaudible] is on their lining.
The theatrical quality of this episode on of the quote unquote a reality.
Two things,
uh,
important to remark and remember from this scene is that Don Quixote meets an
image of his madness.
Something will happen throughout part too.
And it is kind of a point of madness where madness reflects madness,
madness for us as readers do.
And the press also,
we must remember the presence of death,
which is a warning against it.
The seats offered by life,
death devalues all of the allures of life with its presses.
And we have met before in a torso when,
uh,
they,
bump against the church to put it in.
Uh,
finally,
uh,
the,
loop of the story here of this little story of this episode,
goals from deceit to disillusionment from Engonnia to this in Ganja,
if Mikko me Kona and the process by which our story was concocted,
it was like a representation of representation.
The episode of the cart of the parliament of death is representation in motion
or actually representation even on wheels.
One could say,
I want to close by reading you a little vignette that I wrote as an epilogue to
this episode.
Uh,
I've told you that,
uh,
professors and critics can hardly resist that temptation of crossing the line
and becoming writers.
And this is the by various,
my very modest,
uh,
falling into that,
into that trap.
Uh,
it goes like this is very brief and very silly.
Now I say we read it,
but I think that it'll give you a laugh.
Satisfied after recovering Sanchez donkey from the wild devil who had stolen it,
ingest to mock them Quixote.
Our pair got back on the road on their journey to Saragosa.
They had not traveled very much.
When they saw in the distance,
a cloud of dust kicked up by what seemed like a large contingent of horsemen.
Only that from a farther mounds looked enormous,
fit more for giants done for men.
They brought Nantais and the donkey to a halt,
shaded their eyes with their hands and peered into the approaching murky mass,
unable to discern what it contained as when he first saw the cart with the
players.
Don't be hot.
There was brimming with anticipation.
These had the makings of a superb adventure,
fit for his new stature as a knight who's exploit had already been the object of
a book as the strange contingent.
Jr Don Quixote and Sandra were astonished to discover it to the cover that it
consisted of a brightly dressed man in Morris dress,
sitting atop a huge camel and covered by agreeing canopy.
He was comfortably positioned in a,
on a lavish saddle with his legs crossed or which he cried.
A cradled a device that our heroes could not see behind him.
Road in splendid dromedary,
a younger man dressed as a Maurisco.
He too was covered by a parasol yellow in his case and was in a seminar position
and creating something in a fashion similar to the man on the front who was
obviously his master.
They were surrounded by a troop of men on horses.
Well armed and carrying banners.
Both parties stopped and gaze at each other in wonder.
Lucky hot was the first to speak my dear.
Sir,
would you please state your name,
nation and mission as I suspect by your garb and weapons that it could not be a
good one in which case I must challenge you to single combat.
The gentleman somewhat plumping,
placid in appearance did not look,
did not look up from the device on which he seemed to be tapping with both hands
at length.
He lifted his head and answered the night in an incomprehensible gibberish that
demand behind him on the dromedary interpreted nearly at once as follows,
my dear don Quixote that Amanda,
I am seeding,
admitted binning Hayley author of your story and your Creator and the man behind
me is my translator who is transcribing in Spanish.
What I right here in this laptop in Arabic,
he said this without stopping his typing for how he don saw the whole scene
would have vanished without a trace.
Don Quixote and central were speechless and motionless and the tapping ceased
silence fell over the baron Castilian landscape.
The novel had finally and truly come to an end.
What I have here,
a few notes,
shields from your exams that I have of things that I found very interesting is
not everyone.
So don't be jealous if you're not mentioning.
You mentioned in the next one,
but Tony wrote about the lack of introspection in the Quixote.
Uh,
and that is true.
and that,
uh,
he also,
but this will change in part two.
And he also said that the dose who like the Romances achievers are also like Don
Quixote.
And in a way that extends to us,
that was very good.
Kelsey being an author,
uh,
and the danger of insanity,
she writes sanctuary,
which is true.
There is being an author,
uh,
as you can see what my,
my little,
uh,
attempt here,
carries the danger of insanity.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
central she says is fat and short and then therefore closer to the ground.
I found that terror,
a donkey hearted doubles Vantis both our readers and authors of chivalric
romances.
It is true.
Yeah.
So I found that to be Jasmine [inaudible],
Spanish dolus [inaudible] Sandra,
a doubles who in interlaced,
uh,
to complete as it were,
the character of Don Quixote.
That was very good.
I thought,
uh,
[inaudible] found various frames.
Uh,
[inaudible] as is true,
the frame of the picture of the frame in the picture of the frame of the door
there repetition of frames.
I found that to be a very,
very interesting insight.
Uh,
Elizabeth car.
Then you,
it makes no Quixote more believable as a character since someone else exist who
is like him.
Uh,
Toby interning Gnocchi hold this world into a world of dialogue.
He Sankyo both changes and preserves it.
So this is from your own business,
your own feedback that I found very interesting.
So I'll see you in the next class or this Friday.
I will be there.
Should you come?
I want to come see me,
or a few of you have already come and we have had very pleasant conversations
and I am,
uh,
eager to receive you.